uh the time being 9 30 I will call this
meeting long range Capital planning and
utilization committee to order
um
for the record until representative
McConkey makes it he told me he would be
late uh representative Edwards will be
filling in
for him until
reading the wrong Glide representative
Edgar will fill in for McConkey I'm
sorry
um until such time is that the regular
member shows up
um first order of business is the
acceptance of the minutes of the
September 19 2022 meeting are there any
questions errors or omissions
saying none I will accept a motion for
the approval of the minutes
representative Mills moved second by
representative Clooney or the the
minutes of September 19th uh be approved
any discussion comments Cena and all
those in favor signify by saying aye
aye approved nay the ice habit and the
minutes are approved
one item that's not on there just for
those of us who came in for a special
meeting over the summer
um that so that we could uh lease a
building on short notice
that lease was finally approved at the
last GNC
that was not quick work but we will now
move forward with the movement of the
Department of Justice and the rest uh
several months later than we had planned
on
first order of business is under old
business
lrcp
22-26 additional information Department
of administrative services
and information requested September 19
2022 to lrcp
22-26 Department of administrative
services
acting on behalf of the Department of
administrative Services
um
requests approval to Grants an occlusive
option to Gilson Road solar LLC a New
Hampshire limited liability company to
be formed by solar farm developer Andrew
Keller doing business as New Hampshire
solar garden to lease approximately
25.78 acres of land at the Sylvester
Superfund Site located near Gilson Road
in Nashua New Hampshire consistent
primarily of the cap of a cap landfill
and the abiding surrounding state land
for a total term of up to 45 years
following an option option term of up to
two years for the purpose of
constructing and selling operating and
maintaining a one to five megawatt
capacity commercial solar powered
generation facility proposed exclusive
option fees to obtain the right to lease
a subject property are one thousand
dollars for the first 12 months and one
thousand dollars each for two
consecutive option period extensions of
six months and after the option is
exercised and construction is complete
propose annual rent of the initial
25-year lease term is the product of the
nameplate generation capacity of the
facility in megawatts of alternating
current and ten thousand dollars subject
conditions as specified in the request
dated August 30th 2022 this item was
tabled on the 19th of
um
September
what is the pleasure of the committee
does anyone wish to take it off of the
table
representative
Mills moves that the item be taken off
the table is there a second
Ed by Senator birdsil
um the motion is to take lrcp
22-26 off of the table
is there any discussion
saying not in all those in favor signify
by saying aye
I'll oppose say nay the ice habit and
the item is off of the table and
um for us to act on
is there anybody here who has
wishes to speak briefly
um about the item and where we are at
the moment with it
and please identify yourselves for the
record
uh good morning my name is Jared Nyland
real property asset manager with the New
Hampshire Department of administrative
Services
um
uh following the September meeting I
inquired of the Department of energy to
invite a representative to attend this
meeting as requested at the last meeting
the Deputy Commissioner is seated right
back here if you have any questions for
him
um
uh I also submitted a letter uh
generally answering
um what the developer Andrew Keller uh
indicated was his intention regarding
the sale of all the power generated by
this proposed facility
um
so that's where we are any questions
from members of the committee
Senator Birdsall
I just want to clarify so according to
this the intention of the solar
farm is to make all of the elect the
electricity local to New Hampshire
uh yes my understanding is that under
the Community and this is where I'm out
of my depth uh the community power rules
um his intention is to sell all the
power to a municipality uh I I false I
mistakenly assumed it would be Nashua
but it will be a New Hampshire
municipality not necessarily Nashua and
then all the power and then
if you have questions about how the
program works I I highly suggest asking
the Deputy Commissioner
commissioner come on forward
all right thank you uh for the record
Chris Elms Deputy Commissioner of the
New Hampshire Department of energy uh so
Senator to answer your question
um I can't speak to the specifics of
this project but it sounds like the
developer's intention is to participate
in the uh recently approved Community
power aggregation program uh as a part
of that
um you know all the electricity that is
generated and consumed in the iso New
England grid is accounted for
um
you know complex markets will help
figure out what generators are
compensated for that power and what
consumers pay for that power there are
attributes to power that's generated
like whether or not it's renewable
um that are captured by that you know
um uh purchasing and and consumption
um Community power rules will allow the
municipalities to enter you know build
their own electric portfolio figure out
which attributes they would like to
um pursue in some cases that they might
be able to achieve either lower costs or
more stable costs in other cases a
municipality might choose to prioritize
environmental benefits you know have a
certain percentage of their electricity
be from renewable resources
um a town would do so but because they
believe that that agreement would be
beneficial to their Community
um if this developer were to enter into
a an agreement with the town to sell
that power and Achieve whatever those
benefits the town are prioritizing the
benefits of that elect you know
electricity being sold would be captured
by the municipality uh and and the state
further questions from members of the
committee
saying none thank you is there anyone
else who wishes to speak on this item
see none the motion before us is
um
approval of lrcp 22-26
we did have that motion right
oh
representative Mills moves approval
executed by senator birdsil
um that
lrcp026
be approved is there any discussion
seeing none all those babies signify by
saying aye
aye
um
opposed nay the eyes have it and the
item is approved
thank you
next item is RSA 4 colon 39-b approval
of state agency leases exceeding five
years
lrcp
22-45 Department of administrative
Services requests authorization to enter
into a 10-year lease renewal agreement
with Bar Harbor Bank and Trust 82 Main
Street P.O box 400 Bar Harbor Maine for
approximately
4191 square feet of space to be provided
in existing Bill Building located at 15
atriums Road Hillsborough New Hampshire
to house the sixth district division
Hillsborough courthouse for the period
of March 1st 2020 through 3. with rental
payments commencing immediately
thereafter an expiring 10 years later on
February 28 2033 for a total lease
amount of 690
thousand one hundred and eighty nine
dollars and 82 cents subject to the
schedule of annual rent and conditions
as specified in the request dated
November 14th is there anybody from
the department
welcome
can you hear me
my name is Sarah Lineberry I'm the
superintendent of the Bureau of Court
facilities for the Department of admin
services and I have with me today Brian
Young and Brian is assistant
administrator for the Bureau of core
facilities Department of Edmond services
um Mr chairman and committee members we
are here today to seek approval of a
10-year lease agreement between the
Bureau of Court facilities and Bar
Harbor Bank and Trust for
4191 square feet of space
um for the sixth circuit
courthouse located in Hillsborough New
Hampshire
the total cost for the 10-year term is
189.82 cents with an annual rent in the
first year of sixty three thousand
thirty two dollars and sixty four cents
or fifteen dollars and four cents per
square foot
with a two percent annual increase for
the remainder of the term
the circuit court has occupied this
location for more than 10 years and
features one courtroom
Public Service counters public and staff
circulation space a holding area and
continues to meet all the current
Courthouse standards
thank you and we're happy to answer any
questions
I do have one question there is there
are no current plans to build a new
courthouse in that area
that is correct thank you
Senator Birds almost approval of the
item is there a second
Ed by Senator Reagan any discussion all
those in favor of approval of item
22-045 signify by saying aye
aye op postnay the eyes have it and the
motion is approved thank you very much
thank you
moving on to RSA four colon 39-c
disposal of highway or turnpike-funded
real estate
lrcp
22-38 Department of Transportation
request authorization to amend
lrcp
22-16 approved May 23rd 2022 to dispose
of state-owned land located at one
Cronin Road in the town of Exeter by
increasing the acreage sides to 3.16
plus the minor Acres from 2.88 plus or
minus Acres with an increased sale price
of 501 100 to 576 thousand one hundred
dollars which includes a one thousand
one hundred dollar administrative fee
subject to the conditions as specified
in the request dated May 6 2022 I see
that the department is ready
thank you Mr chairman uh I'm Steve
Labonte I'm the administrator of the
Bureau of right-of-way New Hampshire
Department of Transportation as it was
just mentioned this art um this parcel
has been up before the committee before
based on comments for the town from the
town when we went to uh to offer the the
property of the town is required by the
statute
we reconfigured what we're selling
previously we were leaving an A small
area for a truck turn around
the town was looking for that turn
around in different locations so what we
determined was and they had made some
other requests like they wanted us to
donate a 10-foot strip along the front
of the property and and as you know we
we don't have the ability to donate
State Property so what we did is we went
back to the town and said this is
probably more appropriate for you to
address this with the with the buyer
when they go through the planning board
process so uh reconfiguring that we
added a small portion of the property we
added area 0.28 acres
and increased the property value from or
or what our asking price that we're
seeking to ask from 500 1 100 to 576
thousand one hundred dollars we did an
analysis to see what the increase and we
got a general
um
a General market value from anywhere
from four hundred and eighty thousand to
six hundred and five thousand
um analysis done by our chief
right-of-way appraiser kind of put us
right at at the market 576
000.
the property will be sold as is the
buyer will be required to have a
licensed land survey or survey the
property and generate a boundary line
right-of-way adjustment plan which will
ultimately be reviewed by the department
and recorded at the Rockingham County
registry of deeds
um the state will retain a 400 I mean
the state is going to retain uh
a couple of slope a couple of 400 square
foot and a 4275 square foot drainage
easement and a 4 000 square foot slope
easement
I can answer any questions any questions
members of the committee seeing none or
what is the pleasure of the committee
representative McConkey moves approval
Senator Birdsall moved seconds the
motion during discussion seeing none all
those in favor of approval of item
signify by saying aye
aye opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
approved
moving on lrcp
22-39 Department of Transportation
requests authorization to Grant a
permanent utility easement to the town
of Hooksett in the amount of four
thousand dollars which includes an
administrative fee of one thousand one
hundred dollars pursuant to RSA 440
um Roman 3-a subject conditions as
specified in the request dated November
3rd 2022 temporary use and occupancy
agreement was originally granted lrcp
22-18 May 13 2022.
the apartment
thank you Mr chairman the department is
seeking permission to Grant a permanent
Water and Sewer
um easement to the town of Hooksett for
the amount of four thousand dollars
which includes an administrative fee of
eleven hundred dollars uh
the uh it's to serve a the purpose of
the the project is to um
allow the
town to develop a 30-foot wide Water and
Sewer utilities meant from Crossroads
through the abutting parcels to the
north identified as Parcels
3016 and 3017 on a plan titled Fe
Everett Turnpike which was purchased
from
uh for the
p265c Z
in 19 project in 1955
the easement will run along the easterly
edge of a drainage system running
through parcel 9 and along a western
border of parcel 38 the water and sewer
extensions are part of a larger tax
increment Finance effort bring to bring
water and sewer to identified areas in
the town of Hooksett to promote
additional development the department
um
conditions of of this
of the cell is the premises has a storm
water detention Pond located along the
Fe
turn Effie Abra Turnpike and multiple
stockpiles of concrete Jersey barriers
the permanent easement shall be located
and centered between the detention Pond
and the adjacent stockpiles to create
the large ought the largest offset
possible for each
the licensees shall provide and install
stubs and water shut off to the
Department's Bureau of turnpike's
property Administration
um property located at 36 Hackett Hill
Road it was determined the property was
purchased from in 1955 for
3909 uh three thousand nine hundred
dollars uh which was 17 acres and the
other partial 3017 was purchased for
forty five hundred dollars in 1955 which
consisted of
45 Acres an appraisal a staff appraiser
with the Department appraised the value
to be two thousand nine hundred dollars
questions of the department
saying none what's his pleasure of the
committee Mr chairman
representative thank you Mr chairman I
move approval of item
22-039 representative Cloutier moves
approval of item uh 22-39
second new by representative Mills is
there any discussion on the motion
seeing none all those papers signify by
saying aye
aye opposed nay the eyes have it and the
motion is approved
lrcp
22-40 Department of Transportation
requests authorization to sell 0.25 plus
or minus of an acre of state-owned land
within the limited access right-of-way
located on the southerly side
of New Hampshire Route 9 Mount Major
Highway in the town of Sullivan directly
to the town of Sullivan for four
thousand six hundred dollars which
includes a one thousand one hundred
dollar administrative fee
subject to the conditions as specified
in the request dated November 4th 2022.
thank you Mr chairman I'd point out that
the item our request has a typo in it
made by the department it's actually the
Franklin Pierce Highway and and Sullivan
um I apologize for that so the town
would like to acquire the parcel for
location of its uh Broadband head end
for fiber cast
it's high-speed internet they want to
provide high-speed internet to the town
um
the head end is a centralized control
unit where external sources for
programming and data are gathered and
then processed for redistribution out uh
the subject parcel is a prime location
and a short distance from the
Consolidated communication shed uh the
requested access to this parcel will be
off Apple Hill Road partially consists
of a quarter of an acre is a Polish
portion of a larger parcel acquired in
1969 from Vincent and Lucille Wickland
the department acquired the portions
of three separate Parcels at a combined
area of eight eight point seven eight
acres for the sum of 14
500 two of the parcels acquired were
improved with structures that have since
been removed uh the town will be
required to solicit a licensed land
surveyor to survey and prepare boundary
line and adjust and right-of-way
adjustment plan to be submitted to the
department
um
for review and ultimately recorded the
Cheshire County registry of deeds
a staff appraiser from the Department
evaluated the subject property and
concluded it it does have an independent
it does doesn't have an independent
highest and best use they then market
value
they then prepare to market value
appraisal using sales comparison
approach and adhered to the right-of-way
manual requirements the subject
properties market value was concluded to
be thirty five hundred dollars so that
with the 1100 administrative fee brings
us to 4 600.
questions of the department
saying none what is the pleasure of the
committee Senator bird cell moves
approval
uh representative Cloutier seconds the
motion
um any discussion seeing none all those
uh in favor of the motion signify by
saying aye
aye opposed nay the eyes have it and the
motion is approved
lrcp
22-41 Department of Transportation
requests approval to dispose of two
Parcels of state
state-owned land located on Enterprise
Drive formerly known as Indian Head Rock
in the town of Windham by entering into
a listing agreement for a term of one
year with Nia Norwood group at the
listing price of 995
000 for both Parcels allowing
negotiations within the committee's
current policy guidelines and pursuant
to our say 440 Roman 3-a assessing
administrative fee of one thousand one
hundred dollars per parcel and subject
to the conditions as specified in the
request date in November 10 2022
thank you Mr chairman
um
the department will enter into a listing
agreement when Nai Norwood group the
listing agreement will be for 995
thousand dollars uh the department is
processing the disposal to to abutting
Parcels of state land located on
Enterprise Drive in the town of Windham
Parcels were acquired for the Salem
Manchester
104.18c Interstate 93 widening project
the breakdown of the parcels are as
follows parcel a 0.83 Acres
of an improved is improved with a
single-story commercial building
acquired in 2006 from Jay Freda boys
Realty as part of and as as part of a
negotiated settlement which means we had
to condemn on the property
um the price the negotiated settlement
was for seven hundred ninety thousand
dollars this commercial building was
then renovated by the department using
federal funds and used as the
construction field office for the
project
listed above
until June of 2021
parcel B is a 1.47 acre Acres of vacant
land and is comprised from portions of
three separate Parcels the first parcel
was acquired in 1956 and is 0.5 Acres
was 0.5 Acres of from Raymond and Ruth
Dooley for four hundred dollars the
second was acquired in 2007 and was
55.06 Acres from George G Dinsmore
revocable trust and this was also a
negotiated settlement for 4 630 thousand
dollars again that was for the whole 55
Acres 55 plus acres and the last was a a
quarter acre acquired from Gilbert
agedello at four five thousand seven
hundred and fifty dollars
uh these Parcels the parcel we're
selling the second parcel B was is made
up of portions of all of these uh the
buyer will have to get a licensed land
surveyor to prepare a perimeter boundary
line survey
um the buyer shall be responsible for
obtaining all local and state approvals
including but not limited to uh
subdivision approval the Bureau of the
Department's Bureau of environment uh
request recommends it if possible The
Stonewall alignment be avoided and
preserved in place access to the parcels
will be from Enterprise Drive no access
from 111 and the department is retaining
a 15 250 square foot permanent drainage
easement located on parcel B
I thank you
um
I do have one question what if somebody
wants to buy just one parcel
we're not the second parcel is come
completely useless on its own okay so we
won't sell it like that all right
um anybody else have Senator Birdsall no
I just moved to a proof that bird cell
moves approval
seconded by saying Reagan
any discussion
seeing none all those in favor of the
motion to approve this item signified by
saying aye
aye opposite
the eyes have it and the motion is
approved
lrcp
22-42 requests authorization
uh to sell 0.75 plus or minus of an acre
of State on land located behind in a
buddy 512 Eastman Road in the town of
Conway directly to Peyton Cressy the
butter in the amount of fifty six
thousand one hundred dollars which
includes an administrative fee of one
thousand one hundred dollars subject to
the conditions as specified in the
request dated November 10 2022
thank you Mr chairman uh the grantee
submitted a request to acquire the
property described I just described this
parcel vacant land was acquired from
David Smith in 2006 for the Conway
bypass project for seventy one thousand
dollars which included a 344 square foot
temporary construction easement
um
the 0.75 acre parcel acquired for the
project is identified on the project
plan as parcel 51 a staff appraiser from
the Department evaluated the the subject
property properties market value and
determined it was 55
the reason for the decrease in property
is that because we didn't build the
project this property is is basically
landlocked and is only marketable to the
aboutting property owner
thank you one quick question will this
money have to go back to the feds as
part of the club back for us not doing
the project yes
yes this will go back to our payback Our
obligation all right senator dalessandra
we've got to consider I don't have an
exact number I can get you that but um
we've got
a number of properties still left to
sell that we're working through with
further questions go ahead now what
about we did purchase a number of houses
what what are we doing with those Homes
at this time we were renting the world
and some of them were in bad repair and
disrepared truly what are we doing now
so I'd have to check to see what if any
residential dwellings that we're still
leasing up there so if the property I
mean we're selling the properties as is
um and so it is a pretty good demand but
a lot of those houses now that they've
been vacant for 15 years or so they're
in bad shape they'll likely be raised
and something will be built on them
thank you
any further questions or comments from
the committee so you know what's the
pleasure of the committee
representative McConkey moves approval
representative Mills seconds the motion
for approval of the item
any discussion saying none all those in
favor signify by saying aye
aye opposed nay and the item is approved
and someday we will finish paying back
the feds for that project
allegedly
moving on
lrcp-043 Department of Transportation
requests authorization to sell uh 0.2
point plus or minus of an acre of parse
parcel of state-owned land located at
the intersection of Martin Road in new
New Hampshire route 101 in the town of
Epping directly to 46 Martin Road LLC in
the amount of one thousand dollars and
pursuant to RSA 440 Roman 3-a assess an
administrative fee of one thousand one
hundred dollars subject conditions as
specified in the request dated November
10 2022.
thank you Mr chairman uh this uh two
tenths of an acre parcel is a portion of
a larger 18.5 acre parcel acquired in
1962 from James a Letty for the price of
Sixteen thousand
two hundred dollars for the uh for the
Raymond Epping project the parcel is
also identified on the Epping tax map as
36 lot 23.
uh grantee will be required to get a
licensed land surveyor to do a perimeter
boundary line which will ultimately end
up being recorded at the Rockingham
County registry of deeds I've been out
to the parcel it has very little value
to anyone but the butter it's uh it's
landlocked so
I can answer any other questions thank
you any questions see none what is the
pleasure of the committee Mr chairman uh
representative Cloutier thank you Mr
chairman I move
a doctor
representative Clooney or moose approval
representative Mills seconds the the
motion is there any discussion saying
none all those in favor of the motion
signify by saying aye aye opposed nay
the eyes have it and the item is
approved
lrcp
22-044 Department of Transportation
request authorization to sell
0.09 plus or minus of an acre of
state-owned land located between New
Hampshire Route 10 and Ralston Road in
the town of Haverhill directly to the
budding owner Jack Brill in the amount
of one thousand nine hundred dollars
plus an administrative fee of one
thousand one hundred dollars subject to
the commit conditions as specified in
the request date of November 10 2022.
thank you Mr chairman uh the subject
parcel consists of a remaining 8 500
square feet or about just under 0.2
acres of land which was acquired from a
larger uh 14 365 square foot acquired in
1940 for six hundred dollars for the
Haverhill Dartmouth College Road Project
uh the grantee will be required to hire
a licensed land surveyor to prepare a
right-of-way boundary line plan which
will be submitted to the department for
review upon the Department's approval
the plan will be recorded in the Grafton
County registry of deeds it's another
typo and the part of the department
a right-of-way appraiser from the
Department evaluated subject property
and
recognize that it only has contributory
value to this one of butter which is
where they came up with the Nineteen
Hundred Dollar value I can take anything
thank you questions C9 what is the
pleasure of the committee representative
McConkey moves approval sir right
Senator bird silver who's seconds the
motion all those in favor signify by
saying aye
aye opposed nay the eyes have it and the
motion is approved
RSA 440 disposal of Real Estate
f i s 22 Dash
36 Department of Transportation
request authorization at least
approximately 0.7 Acres of state-owned
Ashland Branch Railroad Corridor and the
town of Winchester New Hampshire to
Winchester Precision for one thousand
dollars per year for five years plus a
one-time administrative fee of one
thousand one hundred dollars of which
the department is in receipt of five
hundred dollars subject to the
conditions as specified in the request
dated October 20th 2022.
can you okay off I'm sorry uh chairman
members of the committee thank you for
this opportunity
the Bureau of round Transit was
approached by Winchester Precision
Technologies regarding
an encroachment on the Chevrolet or
Ashland railroad corridor
and I investigated it and found a
historically uh it had been encroachment
since probably 1890s I met with uh the
Bureau of uh trails and they have had
they had no incidents or reported
incidents with uh their snowmobiles
through there so we felt this was an
acceptable option to offer the committee
for consideration
thank you questions from the committee
saying none was pleasure of the
committee
it's an uh representative McConkey moves
approval
seconded by Senator Reagan uh any
discussion on the motion seeing on all
those signif in favor signify by saying
aye
opposed nay and the eyes have it and the
motion is approved we have no
miscellaneous items there are several
informational items listed in your
agenda does anybody desire to go over
the informational items
seeing no desire to do that
um we cannot set the next meeting of uh
the long-range committee we all this
committee dissolves at midnight on the
6th of the December and it will be
sometime in the new year before the
Senate President and the Speaker of the
House appoint new members as well as the
various members from the governor's
office and administrative Services
Etc
so for those departments that do not get
any business in for this one you're
going to wait till February or March
um before that but to the members of the
committee I thank you all for
all of the work that we've done over the
last two years I know that the LBA sent
you all out a listing of what we did
over those two years as far as sales
Leasing and the rest I do have to send
that to the governor the Senate
President Beaker of the house a few
other people that are listed there and
the executive Council on what we
accomplished over the last two years on
this committee so I thank you all for
the hard work and for those who are
coming back hopefully some of you will
say on the committee so that there is
some
continuity and experience that stage
with it I think as you all know I'd
elected not to run so I will not be back
but I will kibbets
excuse me Mr chairman uh yes I would
like to take this privilege to thank you
very much for your service of being on
the committee and sharing the committee
uh I know it's not an easy task being a
former chair of this committee myself
but I think you've done a very
professional job in scheduling our
meetings and I want to thank you very
much for that service hopefully wish you
the best wishes in any future endeavors
and hopefully we'll see you around once
in a while next turn thanks
thank you thank you
Mr chairman I too would like to say
thank you for your service not only on
this committee but your service to the
state of New Hampshire over the years on
public works uh you and and others have
done great service to the state
by being there by working on some very
significant projects over the years so
thank you for your service
um
it's it's it's problem it's problematic
with people that you know today's
today's news is today's news but uh
tomorrow it's all about its history it
is you're making me blush there Senator
but
um thank you
and with that
um this committee stands adjourned to
the call of the next chair